I'm not altruistic, but I am an animal.
Hey there selfless shellfish, Jules here for
DNews!
In 2012, researchers in Monterey Bay, California
observed a group of humpback whales protecting
the body of a gray whale from being eaten
by a group of killer whales for six and a
half hours.
That sounds pretty counterintuitive, since
the humpbacks seemingly got no benefits from
defending another species of animal, but risked
their own safety nonetheless.
Isn’t that against evolution and “survival
of the fittest”?
This altruistic behavior is puzzling, but
it is not unique.
A July 2016 study in Marine Mammal Science
notes at least 115 times that humpbacks have
attacked killer whales, sometimes allowing
the killer whale’s prey to escape.
Humpback whales are not the only ones in the
animal kingdom to show altruism.
And to be clear, this isn't philosophical.
Biologists have defined altruism in nature
as: any behavior that that improves another
animal's health and chances of reproduction,
at the expense of their own.
Dolphins have been noted to protect human
scuba divers from sharks, certain monkeys
will make noise to warn for predators, giving
away their own position, and bats have been
observed sharing food with members of their
group who don’t have any.
According to age-old evolutionary theory,
anything that prevents a species from procreating
will likely be phased out in favor of attributes
that increase chances of procreation.
And for a long time, scientists have pointed
to a sort of “selfish gene”, which is
not actually one specific gene, but rather,
the fact that animals that act selfishly,
at the expense of other members of their species,
will be more likely to procreate and pass
along whatever heredity made them more selfish.
Selfishness begets selfishness!
In this light, altruism should be a recessive
trait, and logically would have been phased
out altogether in evolution, turning us all
into parking spot grabbing, line cutting,
Halloween candy hoarding jerks.
But clearly that’s not the case, at least
not in the animal kingdom.
So, why do some animals show signs of altruism?
In the case of the humpback’s from the beginning
of this video, one hypothesis suggests they’re
actually responding to the killer whale's
predatory calls, on the off chance that it
is attacking another humpback.
Because if it was, altruism would be a useful
tool, since they would then be protecting
more of their clan, and increasing their mutual
chances of survival.
Other forms of altruism, like, a monkey picking
bugs off another’s back, or bats feeding
those without food, are actually reciprocal
behaviors.
So even though you might think, "wow that's
so nice!" in reality, a bug-picking-monkey
will likely get their own bugs picked off
by another monkey, and the same is true of
bats sharing food.
In short, some expressions of altruism may
just be communally paying it forward so that
everybody stays healthy and fed, and is then
able to reproduce in a better environment.
It's almost as if behaving altruistically,
is a bit selfish!
Studies have shown that more closely related
animals can be expected to behave more selflessly
with each other, which makes sense in the
context of promoting a species.
Mothers must act selflessly to their children
to keep them alive, mates must try and protect
each other for procreation, and so on.
Ultimately, while animals may seem to be acting
altruistically, they’re still really just
looking out for themselves and their species.
Special thanks to Kay Jewelers for sponsoring
this episode.
For 100 Years, Every Kiss Begins With Kay.
So animals help others to help themselves,
but what about animals that are actually hybrids
of two species?
We talk about why evolution makes hybrid animals,
right here.
And what about you?
Are you altruistic or just trying to help
yourself?
Let us know down below in the comments, don't
forget to subscribe and come back here for
more DNews every day.